today I'm going to show you how to  upload files to Google Cloud storage  with Ruby here's the file I want to  upload  I'm using the Google Cloud Storage gem  to use the gem you need a project and a  service account key here's my project  and i created my service account key  earlier i'll be uploading via IRB first  i require google cloud and connect to my  project  now I create a storage object  cloud storage cause groups of files  buckets so I need to create a bucket  now I can upload my file by calling  create file the bucket and passing it  the source and destination file names  it's that simple to verify that the file  got uploaded correctly I can use the  console  and there's the picture i uploaded I  hope you found this helpful